all right we're at South by Southwest in
Austin Texas and I'm standing out with
James eager he is the host and CEO of
the Young Turks
it's the biggest online news show in the
world as you guys say what do you think
has made it so popular all these years
well we start a long time ago we started
an online video ten years ago so we got
to establish a beachhead when no one
else is around so what we have is a 100%
organic audience we built that audience
there they trust us they're loyal to us
and so we just had a enormous amount of
time and patience in building a real
audience the fact that we don't spy on
American citizens that we get award if
we go to a judge but we have a procedure
that we have due process that is America
one of the things they say work so well
in the online space is having a voice an
opinion and stuff that you guys you know
do do you think that's a that's a big
factor it is but at what's more
important is being authentic and and so
we're hugely was in fashion but if those
two work together it's an absolute
positive law it is put together by the
American security initiative that I can
guarantee you is funded by defense
contractors actually you want a war so
they can get richer what do you think
the future of media is in the digital
space news media I think we're sit in a
fantastic shape all of us that are in
digital news media because the audience
of television is much much older in
order for them to keep the revenue that
they get from that older audience
they're gonna have to keep doing what
they normally do which is not reach
younger audience which gives us in
digital news media an enormous advantage
so whether you're a j+ your us whoever
else is in digital news they got to be
thinking boy i mean we we pretty much
own the president already given them the
size of the other networks but
certainly on the future